bonjour jean marc alors ce sommet du g20
est décevant pour beaucoup puisque les
dirigeants n'ont même pas amorcé un débu
de coopération pour sortir de la crise
actuelle
mais ce qu'on trouve tout de même dans
la déclaration finale quelques éléments
qui permettraient d'avancer mais écoutez
c'est effectivement très vivement vous
avez raison c'est décevant pour tout le
monde d'ailleurs
à commencer par le prince d'arabie
saoudite mohamed bensalem qui qui était
l'organisateur de ce sommet du g20 et
qui pensent et redorer son image dans
les milieux internationaux mais il
circonstances sanitaires ont obligés à
organiser un sommet en visioconférence
qui n'a pas l'éclat forcément d'un
vision d'un sommet en présentiel ensuite
vous aviez les etats-unis qui sont quand
même le premier pays contributeur dans
le monde qui était représenté par donald
trump qui voulait absolument tenir la
scène comme président alors que tous les
autres pays membres ont reconnu déjà la
victoire de joe biden par conséquent
tout le monde à éviter de parler des
sujets les plus urgents vous en parlait
il ya un instant notamment comme le
vaccin n'a pris aucune décision mais
également tous les sujets qui fâchent
notamment celui de la chine et des
conditions des changes de cette
mondialisation qu'il faudra bien recalé
et puis même de sujets d'actualité
beaucoup plus brûlants comme le
terrorisme l'islam ou l'immigration
alors la seule information forte
c'est le montant de la dette mondiale
qui représentent désormais 3 165% du
pib' mon gars depuis mondial c'est
colossal à ses 85 mille milliards de
dollars c'est absolument gigantesque la
dette c'est trois fois ou presque quatre
fois ça alors ça fait presque plus de
trois années de production mondiale on
n'a jamais vu ça dans l'histoire du
monde
alors dans un excès d'imagination et de
générosité et bien le lait les vallées
les 20 pays membres
les vingt pays les plus riches jumeaux
sont mis d'accord pour alléger ou pour
confirmer l'allègement de la dette des
pays émergents
c'est à dire les pays les plus pauvres
c'est d'ailleurs la seule décision
concrète qui a été prise
on a donc suspendu les rembourser mais
c'est très décevant pourquoi parce que
sur ce total de dette mondiale
les deux tiers sont le fait des pays
riches et la personne n'a de solution
l'arabie saoudite qui pensaient perçu
g20 1
davos du moyen orient est quand même
raté un peu son coup on va beaucoup
hélas comme à déterminer les raisons
cette dette gigantesque est-ce qu'on a
une idée des moyens de réguler système
oui oui alors absolument on connaît
parfaitement bien les raisons de cet
endettement
ça représente principalement le
financement des aides publiques qui sont
déversés dans la plupart des pays c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison ce sont les
pays riches qui ont accumulé un cette
date les prêts les subventions pour
éviter la catastrophe sociale en france
ça représente quand même près de 500
milliards d'euros
ces quatre fois le déficit actuel alors
ensuite vous avez la dette privée des
entreprises parce que vous avez des
groupes industriels qui sont à l'arrêt
alors on connaît en france 1 renault air
france l'hôtellerie mondiale aussi est à
l'arrêt enfin vous avez tout ce qu'il va
falloir payer pour relancer la machine
c'est à dire les plans de relance pour
l'année prochaine alors tout ça dans un
contexte le budgétaire qui est très
mauvais parce que l'effondrement
économique à assécher les ressources
fiscales siècle le fmi a sorti une note
de prévision à l'occasion de ce g20 qui
établit la chute d'activité pour
l'ensemble du monde entier à 5 % en 2020
à l'échelle du monde avec une
incertitude d'ailleurs pour 2021 alors
que le monde aurait besoin de plus 5%
pour sauver l'essentiel de sa population
de la misère le plus grave
le plus grave dans cette affaire c'est
que cette dette remet en cause les
équilibres les conditions d' équilibre
des banques alors après la crise
économique
tout le monde craint un risque de crise
bancaire et de crise financière mais en
deux mots jean-marc parce que le temps
nous file
quelles sont les solutions possibles
alors que des solutions mais y en a mais
elles sont essentiellement politique
on pourra jamais rembourser la dette de
tels belle sauf à mettre à la rue la
moitié de la population mondiale donc
c'est organiser une guerre civile quoi
bon donc il faudra sans doute décidé
d'effacer une grande partie de cette
dette
mais c'est horriblement compliqué parce
que quand vous avez fait une dette d'un
côté vous avez des crédits de l'autre
donc si vous êtes passé la bête vous
ruiner ceux qui ont fait des crédits il
faut décider de ce que l'on va ruiner
alors on pourrait imaginer un système
avec les banques centrales pour qu'elle
reprenne les dettes mais là il faut
encore un accord politique
alors tout le monde fait semblant
d'espérer qu'on va trouver une très
forte croissance économique qui
permettra de gérer tout ça les personnes
en occident n'y croit paradoxalement
paradoxalement le seul pays qui pense
avoir une solution c'est écoutez bien
c'est la chine la chine est sortie de la
crise la chine est le seul pays dans le
monde à attirer les investisseurs
aujourd'hui parce que les investisseurs
ont plutôt confiance dans le système
chinois c'est le seul qui vous à venir
nous aider à rembourser les dettes
parce que la chine a besoin d'un monde
qui tourne elle a besoin de clients
1 donc c'est quand même un peu fort de
café comme disent certains
ça va être difficile à admettre la chine
nous a quand même laissé passer le virus
peut-être la chine sera t-elle la seule
le seul pays à pouvoir contribuer à
sauver le reste du monde de la faillite
staron merci beaucoup jean marc
sylvestre pour votre un éclairage jean
marc sylvestre éditorialiste économique